dangerous flooding from tropical
depression berries threatening 11
million people across the south flood
alerts are up across eight states some
areas could see up to another five
inches of rain Barry made landfall as a
category 1 hurricane in Louisiana on
Saturday but was quickly downgraded to a
tropical storm but don't get too
comfortable Louisiana and Mississippi
remain under a state of emergency more
than 90 people were rescued in several
communities over the weekend Omar
Villafranca is in New Orleans Omar the
storm has come and gone but what are the
conditions there now well good morning
we are here on the south shore of Lake
Pontchartrain we're getting a little bit
of rain right now it's not anything too
bad and step over here we can take a
look this is what Lake Pontchartrain is
looking like right now just a few
ripples this is too calm after the storm
all eyes were on Louisiana as Berry was
making its way onto the state land here
and for the most part people here were
spared these were the sounds as
hurricane berry came crashing onto land
Saturday in Louisiana the water started
coming up pretty quickly
heavy rains tornadoes and winds up to 65
miles an hour
uprooted trees damaged houses and
flooded roads hopefully we'll be okay
we're just we're really nervous so far
more than 90 people trapped in
floodwaters were rescued but now the
sounds are sighs of relief after the
hurricane turned tropical depression
left many who feared the worst unscathed
God has blessed us he's given us life
kept us safe healthy and together we'll
remember this forever floodwaters forced
Don's bar and Mandeville to close but
when the waters receded workers rushed
to get the business back open less than
24 hours ago you had more than a foot of
water inside very resilient look at the
New Orleans city what they went through
and they were up and running the next
day - what you got to do levees that
were recently overhauled after Hurricane
Katrina held up but some levees
protecting people from small bayous did
not with the Mississippi River at
historic flood levels and rain
continuing to drench the region
officials are urging people to remain
vigilant and we're thankful that the
worst case scenario did not happen but
we understand here in Louisiana if
nowhere else that will not always be the
case
only about 300 people are in the state's
twenty-three shelters a little bit of
good news in this is that flights are
starting to go in and out of New Orleans
Airport they're expecting normal
operations hopefully by today and a sure
sign that things are getting back to
normal the bars on Bourbon Street are
back open well that's good news Omar
thank you